in this video we're going to go through
10 math properties that you're going to
want to know so let's go through the
properties and then what we're going to
do is we're going to go through 20
examples together we'll do 10 together
and then the other 10 maybe you can
practice on your own and then we'll go
through those ones together as well so
let's go through the properties these
are super important to know the name so
additive identity and the other key is
when you look closely at the name it
sort of tells you what it is what I mean
by that is if say if you have the
additive identity identity means that
you get the identical quantity back so
when I add 0 to any number let's say a
is a number here A Plus 0 is equal to
itself a so we call that the additive
identity
the multiplicative identity
whenever you multiply by the number one
you get the identical quantity back so
like a times 1 is equal to a so just
remember when you see the word identity
think I'm getting the identical quantity
back now the multiplication property of
zero we know that whenever you multiply
a number or a quantity by zero you get
zero so that's called the multiplication
property of zero
the additive inverse is when you take a
number plus its opposite sign you're
going to get zero for example 3 plus
negative 3 is 0 or negative 3 plus
positive 3 is 0 so that's called the
additive inverse when you add its
inverse you get zero
multiplicative inverse when you multiply
a number of times its reciprocal you
always get one so if you multiply two
times a half you're going to get one or
three times a third you're going to get
one when you multiply by the
multiplicative inverse you get one
associative property of addition now
associative
it's kind of like when you're at school
like who do you associate with who's
your group of friends right notice a B
and C are in the same order but what
we're doing is we're grouping or
associating or putting these first two
quantities in parentheses whereas here
we're putting the last two quantities in
parentheses you'll still get the same
answer whether you add these two first
or these two first
but this is just a way of grouping and
that's called the associative property
of addition there's also an associative
property of multiplication again notice
that these quantities are in the same
order a b c a b c it's just that here
we're grouping or associating the first
two here we're grouping or associating
the last two it doesn't matter which
ones you multiply first you're going to
get the same result in the end
and then for the commutative property of
addition when you think of commuting
like if somebody commutes to work that
means like they they drive or they
bicycle or they walk to work they're
basically moving uh to a different
location and similarly with the
commutative property of addition we're
moving or changing the order a plus b is
the same as B plus a like 2 plus 3 is
the same as three plus two you can
change the order in addition when you
add you're going to get the same result
and it's the same thing for
multiplication there's a commutative
property of multiplication if you change
the order you're going to get the same
result 5 times 2 is equal to 2 times 5.
and then lastly the one that you're
going to want to know is this
distributive property and what this is
is whatever's on the outside of the
parentheses here when it's right next to
that parenthesis it means multiplication
and so what you do is you multiply that
quantity on the outside of the
parentheses into the parentheses so we
have a times x
plus a times y so you're just
Distributing or multiplying into the
parentheses so let's practice now see if
you can get some of these what do you
think for this first one 5 times 1
equals five well I can see that I
started with five I'm ending with five
so this is definitely an identity and
we're multiplying so I would say this is
the multiplicative identity okay for
number two we have two times the
quantity in parentheses 3x minus 4 is
equal to 6 x minus eight what property
is that
well you can see what I did here is I
multiplied that 2 into the parentheses
that's called the distributive property
that's the last one we went over here
for number three we have seven plus
negative seven equals zero now this is
like seven plus the opposite sine of
seven which is negative seven equals
zero that's called the additive inverse
that's this one right here
and for number four we've got three plus
four plus two equals three plus four
plus two here it's telling us to add
what's in parentheses uh three plus four
first that's seven plus two is nine here
it's saying add these last two numbers
together first that's four plus two six
plus three is nine we're getting the
same answer but what do we do we we
grouped a different set of numbers this
is the associative property of addition
okay number five we have ten times one
tenth so ten times its reciprocal is
equal to one that's called our
multiplicative inverse
uh number six we have eight plus zero
equals eight which one is that well you
can see again we're getting the
identical quantity back eight eight
right so this is called the additive
identity whenever you add zero to a
number you get itself
and for number seven we've got x times y
times z x times y times Z notice the
order is the same but the grouping is
different here we're grouping the first
two here we're grouping the last two
that's called the associative property
of multiplication remember there's one
for addition there's one for
multiplication
and for number eight we have five times
two equals two times five
that's ten that's ten right so it's true
that they're equal but what do we do we
change the order so that's called
commuting or commutative property of
multiplication number nine three times
zero equals zero we know whenever we
multiply anything by zero we get zero
and that's called the multiplication
property of zero that's this one right
here
and number ten eight plus nine plus ten
equals eight plus ten plus nine what
happened here
well it looks like there's a change in
order nine and ten became ten plus nine
you're going to get the same answer but
we change the order that's called
commuting in this case it's the
commutative property of addition let's
look at 10 more examples see if you can
do these next ten on your own okay pause
the video and you might want to take a
screenshot of these problems right here
I'll try to stand out of the way so you
can uh test yourself so take a
screenshot of that and see if you can do
these problems and while you do that I
just wanted to let you know if you like
the way that I explain things and you
want to learn more about Algebra 1 or
Algebra 2 college algebra check out my
video courses I'll put a link in the
description below it's where I take you
through a typical curriculum with
explanations of the concepts practice
problems problems you can do on your own
as well and it's a great resource I put
a lot of time and energy into it I think
you'll benefit by those video courses so
check those out but let's go through
these problems together now so number 11
we've got six plus zero is equal to six
which property is that well what I
notice is I started with six I ended
with six that tells me this is an
identity and I know whenever I add 0 to
something I get the identical thing back
that's this first one right here
additive identity
number 12 what'd you get for this one
well here you can see we multiply that 5
into the parentheses
5x minus 5 and that's the distributive
property
for number 13 What's Happening Here we
have five times four times two five
times four times two notice they're in
the same order but the grouping has
changed the parentheses has changed this
is what we call the associative property
of multiplication because you can see
we're multiplying
for number 14 what did you get for this
one e times f is equal to F times e
well you can see we change the order
that's called commuting or the
commutative property of multiplication
number 15 we have 23 times 0 equals zero
what'd you get for that one
well remember anything times 0 is always
equal to zero that's called the
multiplication property of zero number
16 7 times 1 7 equals one what did you
get for that one well we know when you
multiply a number times its reciprocal
you're always going to get one that's
called our multiplicative inverse
and for 17 we have one times four equals
four
notice we start with 4 we ended with
four of course anything times 1 is
itself we're getting an identical
quantity so we're thinking the
multiplicative identity this one here
number 18 negative 12 plus positive 12
equals zero so a number plus it's the
same number but the opposite sign is
going to give you zero it's like they
undo one another and that is called the
additive inverse and for number 19 we
have three plus four plus five equals
four plus three plus five notice we
change the order
with the three and the 4. so that's
called commuting or the commutative
property and in this case it's the
community of property of addition since
we're adding
and then the last example here we have
10 plus 11 plus 12 10 plus 11 plus 12.
notice they're in the same order but the
grouping is different right so the
parentheses are on the last two numbers
here parentheses around the first two
numbers still going to get the same
answer but this is the associative
property of addition so great job if
you're able to
work with these properties so practice
memorizing the names and if you like the
way that I explain things I've got many
more videos like this on my Mars math to
your YouTube channel where I try to
distill down these Concepts that make
them easier to understand for you so
check those videos out I'll see you in
my next video